our oceans are alive with sound sound
that most of us never hear but there's
one man who's definitely listening the
blue whales in the eastern North Pacific
off the California coast make two
primary types of calls you know ones
this very pulse 'iv call this rhythmic
throbbing drumbeat is the a call and
another is a more constant call that you
know kind of a low moan that drops
slightly in frequency
in fact the bee calls blasts at such low
frequency our human ears barely register
the sound equipped with an underwater
critter camp from National Geographic
John and his team head to the waters off
the Central Coast of California to
eavesdrop on their calls
blue whales travel there to feed in the
largest underwater gorge on the west
coast of the United States the water is
rich with krill the team deploys the
critter cam on the back of a blue whale
suction-cup is on what the footage
reveals is a deep water dive nearly a
thousand feet down in the search for a
swarm of krill yet another critter cam
picks up a faint drumbeat just what John
has been waiting for it is the
unmistakable beat of a blue whales a
call as a shape emerges from the
darkness
another blue whale the team discovers
that perhaps this solitary giant isn't
so isolated after all the calls may not
be about food but may be about
companionship instead that's really neat
to see that we have one of the things
we've been really hoping to get which is
some underwater
during a call I'm excited I'm tantalize
that I'm wanting more